[Music]
oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to turbo dismount there
was an update to the game that added two
new vehicles and a whole lot of me
relief a brew I don't even care what I'm
saying anymore there's two new vehicles
line their poses and new maps to play
this is not fast I'm just gonna say
right now this is exactly oh I love it
exactly love it the coolest oh I love it
I'm humping the steering wheel why am i
humping it okay could you guys it's okay
you can calm down now
big ass
[Music]
that is everything except for fast that
is exam hey back a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby baby baby okay what other
poses you got Oh that's safe ooh tell me
like one of your french girls it's oddly
accurate okay all right Neil let's see
how this works out free I'm sure it's
gonna be fantastic we're still going the
wrong way so cannot emphasize how wrong
you're being right now oh my goodness
that was impressive except for when you
died I found the perfect map for you
this one's called mines and death you
can guess what's about to happen oh my
god the face bunk blow me like one of
your french girls oh that was a pathetic
blowing oh oh no obstacles this one's
called the cheese grater I look like
cheese
[Music]
okay this assignment it's completely
nonsense oh my arm
how dare you yes everything yes all of
my yes oh I'm going for a ride after
being proud and blowed intact and okay
Miley you look fabulous darling
that figure gosh starts spinning around
you can mess with the legs and me ha
what wait a minute this is what I asked
for
I'm not sure how this is any better for
you but hey just go for it man I don't
even care anymore
I am so into it yeah Oh God oh the
wheels oh my god I thought that ball was
coming right for me that's what she said
why yes okay I'm with it
drifting to the left okay good got it
with it I'm totally okay this is holy no
no no oh yes was so close friend how are
you doing my name is Morgan liar okay
boy the road of doom are full of them a
doom roads a walkie-talkie bye so
apparently I gotta make it from this
platform into that hole over there
without losing any limbs now I don't
exactly have a lot of speed here but I
make up for it in lots of courage and
nothing could possibly exactly as
planned
[Music]
alright so my hope is that this is
actually gonna swing and slam dunk me
into the basket just like this ah did
that count hey you know that will happen
to me hang on
give me a second slow it down a little
more okay missed that time ball please
okay
have mercy I can feel it robbing
oh man Oh grab on to your ball hold on
for dear life with all my speed and all
my [ __ ] exactly the same as it was the
last time okay
thank you for the nice necklace
bulldozer well spin it if you love fat
lot of good you did Oh monk sorry excuse
me sorry God my way oh come on you
better do a better job clearing than the
other guy did
oh my bottom half is missing well thank
you so much now we we had a lot of suck
last time we need a little bit left of
that roll on less of it but do it again
I won't expect to uh okay well we're
going on an adventure
where'd my ride go where'd my legs go
where'd my everything go oh well then
what are you doing okay where'd your
head go gently and yeah okay you lost a
leg but that's okay we got a lot more to
lose later on so just get in the hole
okay thank you very much and you
shouldn't be going first this no okay
where's your ride oh no no okay but you
still intact so that's good to be honest
I don't even know if this is gonna help
whatever the hell
over there okay I'm it's a nice shape of
I told you over here now
leggo loser how well okay I finally have
the equipment to finally beat you
finally apparently oh all right then
did you just eat me who did that said oh
that was you oh my god
he protected me he protected me what are
you doing over there are you okay are
you all right tip no no no no okay
yeah are you just cleaning up all right
you just sit you just do your thing I'll
be open to no no no oh okay
all right okay okay all right so thank
you for joining me for another episode
of turbo dismount I'm still happy that
they're updating this game I mean I
never thought that they would have gone
in the direction of being hard to kill
but still anyway it's it's a good change
right all right bye buddy
you can check out more turbo dismount in
the description below earth through the
annotation link over there thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]